so in this very short talk I will
explain get to in science fiction terms
now to do this I have to tell a story of
Mikan a person who has to use get to
save herself
that's all good stories this one starts
in space on a small ship with a very big
problem we have a gigantic oxygen leak
and to make matters worse the jetpack is
busted so the air is leaking out the
single astronaut on board my kin is
royally screwed is he screwed because if
it was just the air leak it would be
fine
she could simply go outside grab the
patch kit on the outside of the ship and
just patch it the problem is the jetpack
is busted and she leads the patch kids
be on the inside of the ship I just
can't really go outside the ship without
a jetpack on that doesn't work now of
course she could solve it if she had her
cloning device with her but I was left
at home right before she went into space
so that was mark the only thing she has
is the kick console but was a git
console all things can be solved so any
time you do anything you always want to
start by committing start eight one two
oh four two zero fifteen point two
I am royally screwed when you make a
commit what you're doing is hitting the
Save button in a game or taking a
picture of everything at its current
place in time and then you can always
return to it once you've done that you
can create alternate timelines so
anytime you do something in life or in
programming or anywhere else you start
by making an alternate timeline you jump
to that timeline and then you can start
experimenting so what do you do when
your patch gate is on the outside of the
ship your suit is on the inside of the
ship and busted and we need to do
something well you go to the airlock and
see what happens if you open it
and you drift into space and turn into
space drunk an or whatever so that
didn't work but that's not a problem
because we are on an alternate timeline
so all you do is check out the original
commit now you're back where we started
simple so we can start over and make a
new timeline only this time
Mike and take the precaution she ties
herself to the bulkhead then opens to
the airlock let's the air escape swings
herself out the door grabs the patch kit
stuffs it in the kangaroo purse on her
suit and turns into space junk but now
the space junk has a patch kit so
everything is fine because when you're
on an alternate timeline you can always
jump back to the original one and then
merge the two together as a result Mike
and did not have a patch kit the merge
happens now she does that means you can
patch her jet pack put on our space suit
create a new commit point jump out into
space fly on over and grab the patch kit
which he never used in this timeline go
and create a new timeline grid a new
alternate timeline and patch up the air
leak only problem is the patch kit is
not good enough it only patches half of
it which is not a problem because she's
on an alternate timeline a branch and
whenever you're on a branch you can
always check back to the original
timeline again then she can just merge
the two together and now in her original
timeline she has a patch kit I have
patched air leak and ability to go back
in time grab the original patch kit
again and pass the other half
now if you're doing any kind of
programming this is usually where things
go wrong you started working on a
project then you went I need to do
something else you made another timeline
or other branch you messed around with
it and you try to merge everything
together and then you get this nice
little message saying there's a conflict
and then you go delete repository
download start over do you see what's
actually happening it get is saying hey
you're trying to do two things in the
same place it doesn't actually work I'm
not going to try to fix that for you you
have to fix it so you have an overlap
and all you have to do is jump into
space find the two patches that are
overlapping and just edit one of them
make another commit and everything is
fine the only problem is my kin still in
space and she kept opening the damned
airlock so now she has no air and when
you have no air and you're on a
spaceship your friendly AI will tell you
are you sure you want to do that which
is the best error message ever written I
think
the problem of course is she has a patch
to air supply but no air but she also
started the whole process by committing
the starting point which means you can
just go back to the starting point where
she has 70% air recommit it in a new
timeline and rewrite history if you're
going to get and you create an alternate
timeline or a branch and you rebase it
you're in fact applying something that
happened in the past to the future so
when she goes back in time grabs air and
puts it into the future so using it to
use one patch kit to fix fix three
different problems and borrowed air from
the past to save herself in the future
like I said science fiction explains
this of course you're all super confused
right now so here is get in terms of
science fiction see it actually solves
everything for us first of all get the
software runs on your computer github is
where you start us off are in the cloud
so all the people can collaborate to
that software a repository is your
universe
that's where everything lives for your
project a git commit is the save point
that you create as you work forward any
commits you make you can always return
to at any time and you're literally
resetting the universe to that state
I get branch is an alternate timeline
once you create branches you can jump to
any branch at any time and any commit
within that branch at any time then you
can make as many as you want I get
checkout is a time machine that allows
you to jump between the branches and it
allows you to jump between the commit
point merge is when you take two
timelines and version together if you
ever watch space like what does it call
the supernova the worst science-fiction
movie ever made
no one just watched it they're as good
if you ever watched it you'll understand
why that's relevant a conflict is when
you make a change in the same place in
two timelines and try to merge them
together and to resolve a conflict all
you have to do
is just go and fix it yourself rebase is
literally rewriting history
you take one timeline you stick it on
top for another one as if that was
always where it was a fork is when you
take one universe and create another
universe that's an exact copy whereas a
clone is if you create an empty universe
and I clone the content from one you
reverse into that one a push is if you
take the contents of one timeline and
stick it onto another timeline a fetch
is we grab the content from one timeline
and pull it into yours without merging
it a pull is if we do the same thing but
you actually merge it to your timeline
and the air everyone runs into detached
head the end of all attempts are using
get all that's happening here is you
made a change and then jump back in time
and you didn't save the change first and
to fix it all you have to do is create a
new branch and it automatically catches
itself now the last thing else phases if
you've ever tried to use git you likely
start on a command line and that was
likely the end of your attempt so don't
let that command line deter you because
there are better options right now we
have to github desktop with just
everything for you links to github and
source tree which is the same thing but
also links to bit book so as you can see
if you think in science-fiction terms it
makes sense now that you've seen this
you wish you could go back in time to go
like oh now I understand I want to see
that Story one more time good for you
I checked out my timeline before I came
here and you can go to my blog at Morton
comm you can see the annotated version
of this entire talk right
if you check